[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about one of the most
misunderstood characters an attack on
Titan Amir we're going to go through
everything you need to know about this
mysterious badass and after that we are
going to break down her specific Titan
powers and unique abilities everyone
watching regularly thank you for all the
support especially pretty absolutely
insane response we've been getting from
these attack on Titan videos if you're
new be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell because there are many
more attack on Titan videos on the way
now without further ado let's get back
to everyone's least favorite training
corpse graduate Amir a quick warning
there will be manga spoilers so proceed
with extreme caution or abandon ship now
now let's start at the beginning many
decades ago there lived a girl without a
name or a home she lived in the streets
of Marlay as a beggar
she was also ldm who were a group of
people that were greatly discriminated
against by the Marlay people because
they had the potential to turn into
titans an ancestor of the LDN people
Amir Fritz was thought to have made a
deal with the devil in exchange for
these titan powers the titan powers were
supposedly
used by the LDS to overthrow the
existing government allegedly the LD
ends while in power were cruel and
mistreated the Merlin people thus when
the Marlon people came back into power
they treated the LDS who they saw as
monsters with great cruelty and
restricted their movements to designated
areas they were also forced to wear
identifiable stars on their arms like
Jewish people were during World War two
we do not know how much of this history
is accurate because as 1984 has taught
us those who control the present control
the past and reconstruct it in such a
way that serves their purposes
nevertheless this homeless nameless
girls LDN origins only exacerbated her
desperate situation however one day she
was found by a man who gave her a name
he named her Amir after the ancient Amir
frit and brought her to a cult where she
was worshipped by many LDS
the newly named Amir chose to go along
with her new role because it seemed to
bring wealth and happiness to those
around her as you can see commuter was
selfless even from a young age
however the call was eventually
discovered by the public security
authorities and the man who named her
and used her to get rich sold her out
and claimed that she tricked him the
young Amir stood by her given name the
only name she'd ever known and was
arrested with the other cultists because
she was a symbol for a mere fritz and by
extension 4ld and power and LD and
restorationist hopes Amir was paraded
around Marlay and got stoned by angry
citizens
she was taken along with the other
cultists to the island of paradise and
injected with a titin serum for the next
sixty years she roamed outside the
walled Maria as a mindless Titan she
would later refer to this experience as
an endless nightmare then OVA laying
there a member of the survey corpse that
resembled Amir encountered an abnormal
tighten that bowed before her and refer
to her as lady Amir it is likely that
this Titan was one of the cultists from
our lay in 845 Amir's Titan encountered
rainer
Bertolt and Marcel as they were making
their way towards la marea in order to
infiltrate it she attacked rainer but
Marcel pushed him out of the way and was
devoured in his place in this way Amir
obtained the power of the jaws titan
which some fans called a dancing titan
from our cell and turned back into a
human for two years she lived within
wall sheena as a beggar it was at this
point that she overheard a conversation
between members of the church of the
walls and learned the truth about
historia she enlisted in the military in
the hopes of delivering historia to the
marlins in exchange for her own pardon
but quickly developed feelings for
historia who went by the name of Krista
it is implied that Amir even held back
during the training because she wanted
Chris the terrain temp into training
corpse so that she would have the safer
option I've joined the military police
even though she ended up joining the
survey corpse instead Amir even asks the
storia to marry her as early as chapter
5 in the manga after the colossal Titan
attacks the trough district
at lugar castle Rainer notices that a
mere can read a label on a food can
despite the fact that it is written in a
language unknown to the other members of
the squad this can has to be from our
lay and the language is likely Marlin or
possibly LD and if the LD ins have their
own written language when they get
attacked by the Titans Amir reveals her
Titan form in order to help save the
others while as the story pointed out
she could have used her speed and
maneuverability to save herself if she
wanted to later
Ameer gets taken along with Aran by
Rainer and bertolt surrounded by trees
Emir has a great advantage with her
small but agile Titan form and knows she
can escape if she wants to but again she
thinks about historia thinking that it
is not safe inside the walls
amia wants them to get historia and
bring her with them although she
actually tells her story that she needs
to hand her over to save herself because
the Marlay government is unlikely to
pardon him years past crimes if she
doesn't of course the Malayan government
would very much like someone with royal
blood on their side like historian
because only one with royal blood can
fully use the power of the founding
titan the court in power because of this
Emir knows that the Marlins would keep
his story alive the story responds to a
mere seemingly selfish request with a
smile and promises to always be by a
mere side later during the battle
historians that Amir has been trying to
protect her once again she tells a mere
that they should only live for
themselves and says that she will never
fear anything as long as Amir's at her
side around this time erin makes contact
with the Titan of Deana frits a member
of the royal bloodline and activates the
power of the coordinate which Emir
bertolt and rain are all scents this
power allows him to control the will of
other Titans and Amir realizes that this
power could be a future within the walls
for historian if Aaron learns to control
the power the Marlon government will be
unable to threaten the people of
paradise because Aaron could just send
the countless colossal Titans in the
walls to destroy them then to everyone's
surprise instead of returning with this
story and the survey corpse to the wall
Emir decides to turn
back and help Rainer and Bertolt who are
being attacked by the Titans do two
errands coordinate powers afterwards she
said she came back because they couldn't
go back empty-handed tomorrow a
government Rainer even attempts to let
her go but she says that she's tired and
it's her way of paying them back because
their actions led to her regaining her
human form and meeting historian later
amia writes a letter to historian before
she is eaten by Galliard Marcel's
brother who ends up inheriting the power
of the Titan along with her memories in
the letter she writes that she lived her
new life with almost no regrets after
devouring Marcel except she wished that
she got to marry historia and that she
got to express her lover so that is
everything you need to know about him
years difficult and mysterious life now
let's turn to her Titan form some fans
especially anime only fans call Amir's
Titan the dancing Titan but it has been
revealed in the manga that the correct
name for this Titan power is jaws as the
name implies this Titan has a very
powerful draw along with extremely
pointy teeth and nails jaws has the most
biting strength out of all the Titan
powers and this power can be used
against other Titans or against many
structures like railroad tracks the
abilities of the jaws Titan also
includes speed and agility although this
Titan form is only 5 meters Paul
significantly smaller than volt the
height actually makes it easier for the
possessor to maneuver in certain
terrains
for example the mayor has stated that in
a forest her chimpanzee like Titan has
an extreme advantage over other Titans
Galliard version of Jaws seems to
suggest that it is also possible for
this Titan to harden the skin on his
fingers and jaw it seems like multiple
Titans had this ability to harden at
least parts of their body along with the
other Titans jaws has the power to
regenerate a mirror also could
temporarily emerge from the nape of her
Titans neck and speak to historian even
while the lower half of her body is
still fused with the Titan this suggests
that Emil was skilled at using her Titan
powers Amir could even speak in her
Titan form although not as well as he
could but to be fair Zeke had more time
to master his Titan powers camere is
also the only Titan that we've seen that
looks virtually the same at her mindless
Titans
and her intelligent shifter form it is
thanks to a mirror that we know that
people do not age physically when
they're in a Titan form and if they do
eat a shifter they will turn back to the
age that they were before they became a
Titan even if that was 60 years ago
however a mirror did say she was tired
to Raynor and Bertolt which might be a
side effect of her chronological age
which is between 70 and 80 years old as
always there's so much to be learned and
so many mysteries still remaining but
that's why I love attack on Titan so
much it always keeps us engaged and
thinking and there we have it guys
Aamir's life story and the power of the
drawers Titan explained as you can see
although Emir puts on a cold and selfish
front most of the time she is in reality
caring and selfless even if she doesn't
want anyone to know about it
thank you if you stuck all the way to
the end of this long ish video you guys
are the best if you enjoyed this video
be sure to go jaws mode on that like
button and subscribe for more attack on
Titan videos there are many more on the
way also join our discord which I'll
link in the description so you can talk
about anime 24/7 with the coolest
cowboys around and until next time see
ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]